yesterday  you arrived after the queen  i got lost oh how could you get lost  you've lived over the hill for years  it looks different now  everything looks different  you sure you went late yesterday because  you were delayed by someone  why would you think i got delayed by  someone oh come on come on  they are circling us didn't you know  don't you read  it seems the circling just me  not you  just me  the thing is diana there has to be two  of you  there's there's two of me there's two  father two of everyone  it's the real one  and the one they  take pictures of  you have to be able to make your  body do things  you hate  that you hate  yes  for the good of the country  the country  yes the people  because they don't want us to be people  i'm sorry i thought  [Music]  [Music]  you